Nitric oxide question. Dr. McCola have exercises that I think are supposed to increase nitric oxide.
They take four minutes to do and are supposed to do them three times a day. I've been doing them for over a year and feel a year and a half and I feel good when I do them.
Also, the biologic dentist I'm seeing once we take a supplement called Neil 40, which is a nitric oxide boosting supplement.
I read somewhere that nitric oxide isn't good for people with cancer, had a small breast cancer, tumor removed last April.
I know that I still have circulated to ourselves in my body. Are these exercises good to do?
How about a nitric oxide supplement? Yeah, not now, is there any time they would be okay or good to take? How do I know?
So nitric oxide is a phenomenal is a nutrient that your body actually will make.
And it's a nutrient that you take it in a lot of things too. Partly through the gluteus island pathway.
Nitric oxide functions in largely in the endothelium. So the endothelial layer is the layer of epithelial cells that line with the vascular system.
All your arteries are made up of the interior lighting is called the endothelium and it's a single cell layer of epithelial cells.
Right underneath that endothelial layer is smooth muscle layer and that smooth muscle layer is controlled by neurologically through the sympathetic and parasympathetic nervous system.
So it is autonomic nervous system controlled. That's the control of your blood vessels. You don't think I'll contract with blood vessels and they contract or relax with blood vessels.
And they relax if they're on and off through the autonomic nervous system that sympathetic comparison with the control.
And then there are tons of different receptors on those muscle layer cells that will uptake nitric oxide and other things
that will cause relaxation by thereby dilulation and constriction of those muscles thereby constricting the blood vessels and thereby increases the blood pressure.
So if you have high blood pressure, taking nitric oxide supplementation and I think there's a lot better supplementation than the deal with 40.
Sorry about right now but somebody with high blood pressure should strongly consider nitric oxide supplementation.
The problem with that with cancer is that nitric oxide also stimulates a wonderful thing called vascular endothelial growth factor which is, which is how you make new blood vessels and what you want if you have history of cardiovascular disease any type of cardio problems.
You want an uptick in a vascular endothelial growth factor because you could actually create you grow what are called an astymol seed vessels that help feed the heart and other tissues.
And nitric oxide, like I said, will will relax the smooth muscles and cause dilation of vessels thereby decreasing blood pressure.
So, great thing right yeah but the problem is is if you have if you have a growing cancer, especially and we're not talking about blood cancer, talking about hard cancers here so not academia.
But a lymphoma yes and any other regular cancers that we're talking about if you have a mass of any kind, you increase your nitric oxide production, you are going to increase your vascular endothelial growth factor long story short, you do not want to increase vascular endothelial growth factor if you have a hard tumor because you will increase the growth of blood vessels into the tumor.
If you're feeding the tumor better and they're my causing the tumor to grow.
So, the standard rule is you're basically treating cardiovascular disease patients and cancer patients,
especially if they have a mass, so let's say this case, this person, this question said I had a small breast cancer removed, I still understand I have searched the tumor cells in my body.
So, you don't have a tumor right now, could you do nitric oxide exercises for sure, could you take even a nitric oxide supplement, I would say no, unless you have any signs of high blood pressure.
Because if you have normal or even low blood pressure and you take nitric oxide supplements, that could be a problem too, so you could have too much relaxation of endothelial smooth muscle and you could, you could cause a disease and all sorts of things too.
So, that's not a good thing for everything, your body's well balanced.
But if I had a mass in my breast that was palpable and I'm still dealing with it, there's no way I would touch any nitric oxide supplements whatsoever, nor would I take nitric oxide, nor would I do nitric oxide exercises.
So, if I have, you know, a pancreatic cancer, I have colon cancer, if I have, you know, breast cancer or any, any no mass whatsoever in my body that was cancerous, you do not do any nitric oxide, you're increasing vascular and ethereal growth factor, you're going to worsen your problem.
I mean, big time, it could cause growth, so don't do that.
But remember, anything you read about your listening to things, this is great, you're learning things, you know, nitric oxide, you get talked to somebody, I think it was Dr. Nathan.
That's his last, that's his last name.
He wrote a book on nitric oxide, of course, you write a book on it and it's the world's best for everything.
You got to understand a balance of everything, right? So, nitric oxide, your body does make it, you do get it in your diet, you get it in your, that's why we tell people not to eat kale shakes, if you have cancer, because it's the highest in nitric oxide.
If you had nitric oxide, it'd greatly be vegetables, so it's good, you need that balance, but you don't want an abundance of it with any type of cancer.